you
[Music]
welcome to quantum unity for computer
scientists happy Valentine's Day we will
learn about this most romantic of all
subjects quantum computing this is a
talk aimed at computer scientists we
will not go over very much if any
physics during this talk we won't go
over like the double slit experiment or
uncertainty principle we're not we're
not learning about any of that this is
we're gonna come up with a computational
model which you all be finding fairly
intuitive I think use the state machine
and we will run a quantum algorithm on
it show that it up performs a classical
computation model and then we'll end
with some demos including a running
program in Q sharp Microsoft's quantum
language this is the gate quantum
computation model it looks a lot like
the classical computation model where
you have like bits and you send them
through logic gates and transformations
are applied to them there's another
computation model called the quantum
annealing model which is used by d-wave
if you've heard of that that's something
different from what we will be going
over but people think they might be
equivalent the jury's still out on that
anyway I'm sure you'll have a great time
so I'm sure all of you have your reasons
for being here but here are three
reasons I've come up with if you need
some additional convincing why you
should learn quantum computing the first
is that quantum supremacy is expected
this year this very year quantum
supremacy means we have a real problem
running on a real quantum computer which
in real time runs faster than the same
problem on a classical computer so
Google has announced they think they'll
do it this year if they do it's a really
big thing all right so it might be in
your future who knows five ten years we
could all be running some really tricky
problems on quantum computers so we have
lots of large companies Microsoft Google
until IBM they're all investing billions
of dollars in quantum computer
developments there are lots of really
exciting applications this is the one
that everyone's heard about Shor's
algorithm when this paper came out it
lit the world on fire people like wow
chronometers could actually a real
economic impact we could factor RSA and
undermine our global financial system
which is pretty cool here's one that
programmers will I think appreciate
which is we can search an unordered list
in square root n time
so you think they're an unordered list
you have to check every element that's
when you can just get a nice speed up
just square root n queries on a quantum
computer which is pretty pretty nifty
generally useful and here's the one
which i think is probably probably is
the the best probability of change in
the world story programmers scrote and
search probably won't change the world
too much which is we might be able to
have an exponential speed-up in
simulating quantum mechanical systems so
things like drug design if you simulate
like biological molecules interacting
things like that it could like massively
speed-up a lot of our biological
research and everyone talks about like
nitrogen fixation and for this that's
like part of the main Microsoft sales
pitch but this is the one that actually
motivated me the bottom one which it's I
think from talking to come before the
presentation we can also motivate to you
it's intellectually interesting and it's
interesting because it's just kind of
outside my intuition like I think all of
us at this point in our careers can
basically look at any digital or
mechanical system and have like a
ballpark idea of how it works right but
if you look at a quantum computer like
how can a quantum computer uh perform
classical computation it doesn't make
any sense like it's there's no way I can
even like start to guess how it would
work and so I really wanted to learn it
and I think there's a reason for this
and this is kind of getting a bit
philosophical but our language our
informal language that we use developed
in a very classical world it is simply
not equipped to deal with the quantum
world and this is why any pop science
article you've read on quantum phenomena
it doesn't really ring true that all the
metaphors they they don't really make
sense because we're trying to express it
in this language which developed in a
classical world we need to learn a new
language which is the language of
mathematics and that is the only thing
which will actually let us understand
quantum mechanics is to learn it
mathematically all metaphors and
analogies will lead you astray there's a
famous quote here by a physicist named
David Merman which is shut up and
calculate with regard to quantum
mechanics so some grad students maybe
they leaned back in their chair and
they're like huh what does this all mean
shut up and calculate just trust the
math and that is the only thing which
will not lead you astray ok here's how
this presentation will break down first
we're going to learn how to represent
computation using super basic linear
algebra
matrices vectors matrix multiplication
then we will generalize that to learn
about qubits superposition and quantum
logic gates and finally we will use all
those tools we've developed to go over
the simplest problem where a quantum
computer uh performs a classical
computer this is called the Deutsch
Oracle problem I mean there are a bunch
of problems but this is the simplest and
finally it's it be almost negligent to
let you get out of here without learning
about quantum entanglement and
teleportation just because with the
tools we'll develop they're like so easy
to understand so we'll have bonus topics
and then we'll have some demos alright
let's get to it
you'll become very very familiar with
these two vectors this is how we
represent a 0 and a 1 the the two values
of one bit in classical terms so the top
one it's just 1 over 0 and the bottom
one is just 0 over 1 you can also write
them in that weird like angle bracket
thing that's called direct vector
notation so you have a 0 and there are
less means this is the value of that
vector if you have trouble remembering
this just think of it like an array
indexed from 0 and so there's a 1 in the
0 with index that means it's a 0 there's
a 1 in the first index that means it's a
1 ok
everyone's fine with this you'll be very
familiar with this by the end of the
presentation we're gonna go over matrix
multiplication really quickly so yeah ok
the way to think about matrix
multiplication just to review for you
most of you will have gone over this in
your linear algebra courses like the
first or second day so if we have a
matrix multiplied by a vector you kind
of like take this horizontal row and
then flip it and multiply it point wise
with these vector values so a times X B
times y and that's how you get the top
one then you do the same thing in the
bottom row C times X D times y you get a
2 vector the same thing happens with 3
by 3 matrix a times X B times y C times
Z and you get this matrix you can also
by our sorry this vector you can also
multiply matrices together we won't
really be doing much of that and there's
a very special matrix called the
identity matrix which
Zero's everywhere except for ones along
the main diagonal and anything
multiplied by the identity matrix is
itself it's just like multiplying by one
in fact usually you refer to the
identity identity matrix by the symbol 1
now thankfully for simplicity a lot of
the matrices will be using look a lot
like this there are mostly zeros with
just some ones and you can notice is a
nice rule of thumb that relative to the
identity matrix this matrix has the
middle two rows flipped okay and that's
actually the action it has on anything
it multiplies so it flips the middle two
rows it's a nice sort of rule of thumb
to remember how matrix multiplication
works does anyone have any trouble with
this because you really need to know
this in order to go ahead like you gotta
know it okay great operations actually I
like to me I'd like to make this a quiz
can anyone tell me what are the four
operations on one bit there's four of
them
one bit and or those are on two bits Oh
identity not sub-zero settle one there
we go good yes so we have identity just
f of x equals x negation FX equals not X
constant zero it's always set to zero
constant one it's all set to one you can
see with the diagram how it kind of
looks okay and we can write these is
matrices so the identity is just the
identity matrix this remember is our
symbol for zero identity x zero is zero
and any x 1 is 1 here's negation you
flip it from 0 to 1 and 1 to 0
same thing for constants your constant 1
so I hope I've convinced you we can
represent very simple functions at least
with matrices multiplied by R 0 and 1
vectors ok and remember these four
functions because I will quiz you later
on them they'll come back up
so let's talk about reversible computing
reversible computing is a neat sort of
buzzword if you've ever read the popular
sci-fi book excel or on dough it talks
about reversible computing and basically
it means that if I tell you the
operation I did and the output of that
operation you can always tell the input
of that operation if the operation is
reversible so intuitively operations
that just shuffle bits around like
permute them they are reversible but
operations that like erase bits and then
overwrite them are not reversible and in
our previous slide identity and negation
are both reversible because I say the
output is 1 and I put it through the
negation gate that means the input was 0
you can always tell that but if I say
the output was 1 and I put it through
the constant 1 operation you can't tell
what the input was it's not reversible
it erases information and the nice thing
about quantum computing which you can
remember is that mono computers only use
reversible operations those are the only
ones we care about so the only operation
we actually care about on the slide is
really negation like also identity but
it's the same as doing nothing a further
fun fact about corner computers is
they actually only use operations which
are their own inverses so now though not
only are they reversible but if you
apply them twice you'll just get back
the same input value and we're gonna go
in a little this is kind of like an into
pop science but whatever there's
something called the von Neumann
Landauer limit which is the smallest
amount of energy physicists have
calculated is necessary for the simplest
possible calculation which erases is non
reversible and reversible computing
might eventually let us go beyond that
limit more efficient than that
theoretical limit now currently
processors are millions of times use
millions of times more energy than the
von Lohmann lend our limit but you know
50 hundred years from now who knows
pretty nifty all right this is something
you probably did not go over in linear
algebra but don't worry it's still
pretty simple it's called the tensor
product so if you have the tensor
product of two vectors it's kind of like
you take the second vector and you tile
it for each element in the first vector
so x0 gets its own copy and x1 gets its
own copy and then you multiply it out so
you get eventually X 0 y 0 X 0 1 1 etc
it's might be easier to look at this
with real numbers here we have 1 times 3
1 times 4 2 times 3 and 2 times 4 to get
this here's how it looks like with 3
vectors you get this like giant array
don't worry about it too much and I'd
like to point out that if we use our 0
and 1 values you end up with a vector
which has a 1 in only a single position
ok does anyone have any real trouble
with this concept if I gave you two
vectors you could probably calculate the
tensor product it's not entirely
difficult all right but the the final
point I made leads into how do we
represent multiple classical bits and we
represent them by their tensor product
so 0 0 remember we tensor this is our 0
symbol 0 tensor with 0 is this product
state we call it 0 1 is this product
state 1 0 is this product state like 0
times 1 0 0 times 0 0 1 times 1
one one times zero zero okay and one one
is this product state and similar do
just the single bit you can think of
this is an index in this vector array so
this is zero there's a one at the zero
with position this is one there's a
value with the first position counting
from zero and this is two value at the
second position three value at the third
position okay this is the only time I
will tensor three bits together
thankfully because they use you notice
they grow exponentially in size but it
works for this so four is 1 0 0 you have
0 1 2 3 4 is where the 1 bit is okay
yeah so we call this the product state
we can always factor it out into its
individual states and the product state
of n bits is a vector of size 2 to the
end here we see a sort of whisper of the
power of quantum computing this
exponential term but hold that dot we'll
get back to it so we're going to learn a
very important operation very
fundamental to reversible computing and
quantum computing it's called C naught
or conditional not it operates on a pair
of bits you designate one bit the
control bit the other bit is the target
bit so the control bit if it's 1 it
flips the target bit if it's 0 it leaves
the target bit alone and the control bit
is always left alone so if we have the
most significant bit of a two bit system
is control the least significant bit is
target then 0 0 since the this is the
most significant bit it's the target bit
it just goes to 0 0 0 1 goes to 0 1 now
1 0 since the control bit is 1 maps do 1
1 right because it flips the other bit
and 1 1 since it again flips the the
target bit goes to 1 0 okay and this
matrix you can actually kind of write it
you see there's like a sort of
correspondence here we flipped the
bottom two rows versus the identity
matrix and this I claim which I will
show the next couple slides will change
our product States according to the
semantics of C naught so as everyone get
the semantics here we have a control bit
in a target bit control bits one we
flipped the other bit pretty good ok now
this is a lot of math but don't panic
we're going to go over step by step if
we apply let's see
not gate to10 remember that this is the
control bits one so we're gonna flip the
other bit so I'm expected to go to one
one now let's expand this out step by
step so one zero corresponds to this
tensor product this is the matrix from
the previous slide and we're applying it
to our product state remember chicken is
just going to flip the bottom two rows
so we get to this product state which
when you factor it out
indeed gets us one one okay now let's do
with one one same thing we have our
familiar matrix multiplied by this
product state we go to here which we
factor into one zero so I hope I've
convinced you at this point that we can
use matrices to represent kind of more
interesting logical operations than just
a bit flip does anyone have any trouble
yes factoring always possible or
practical for a larger vectors it is
practical yes not always possible which
kind of we'll get into that when we get
into quantum entanglement basically
right good question okay so this is this
is fine for everyone everyone nobody's
lost in the the gigantic equations here
okay we're gonna go over 1 0 then our
sorry 0 0 0 so the the control bits 0
that means we're gonna leave the other
bit alone right and we see that indeed
this is what we do and same with 4 0 1
okay so everyone well maybe you're maybe
familiar with how classical computers
are like real CPUs they're they're all
built on the sort of NAND gate like
everything is fundamentally built on
land and the C note is kind of the
analogous NAND for reversible computing
it's like a really basic thing that is
used to build up larger and more
complicated logical statements like so
I'm sure if I gave you a task like build
some more complicated logical formula
with C naught you probably be able to do
it at this point you just like stick
them all together and eventually it
comes out I will note that it's not
actually universal you can't make every
logical function with a C not gate you
need something called it to fully gate
but we won't we won't see that in this
presentation and we've learned
everything we need to know about how to
use linear algebra excuse me to
represent classical computation
and we can now go on to quantum
computing so to recap we learned that we
can represent classical bits and vector
form is 1 0 for 0 and 0 1 for 1 we can
represent operations on bits by
multiplications on their bit vectors we
learn how the quantum computers only use
reversible operations and in fact the
operations are their own inverses and
multi-bit states we write is the tensor
product of our single bit States finally
Melina robot learned about C naught
which is a very fundamental gate in
reversible computing and quantum
computing so this is anyone everyone's
following along so far this is pretty
pretty simple right it's not that bad ok
let's make the jump qubits and I will
surprise you we've been learning using
qubits all along actually the C bits are
just special cases of qubits and we've
Reps them to keep it in general by a
vector of two elements a B or a and B
are complex numbers don't worry we'll
only use real numbers for this
presentation we're keeping it simple
only in real numbers and we have the
constraint that a squared plus B squared
is 1 so 1 0 and 0 and fit this
definition because 1 squared plus 0
squared is 1 and 0 squared plus 1
squared is 1 right now here are some
example qubit values this is one with
which you'll become very familiar it is
1 over root 2 1 over 2 can anyone tell
me what 1 over 2 squared is 1/2 exactly
1/2 plus 1/2 is 1 so this is a cubic
what about 1/2 and root 3 over 2 what's
1/2 squared 1/4 so 1/4 plus 3/4 is 1
here's an interesting thing we can
actually use negative numbers now
because the negative number squared is a
positive number so negative 1 squared is
1 1 plus 0 is 1 and the same thing here
it's just the same as this first matrix
but one of the values is negative pretty
neat
not bad so far right ok but you might
say this is kind of like saying that a
qubit has a value which is not 0 1 but
actually both 0 and 1 at the same time
this is called superposition everyone's
probably heard of the Schrodinger's cat
being both alive and dead
that's just like a pop sciency way of
articulating this concept sort of and
the interesting thing about a qubit
being in superposition it means we can
kind of I want to really qualify this
kind of compute with the values of both
zero and one at the same time which
again is the sort of whisper of some
quantum speed-up power okay now how this
works is when we measure this qubit it
collapses to our familiar values of zero
and one with some probability and this
is what we usually do at the end of a
quantum computation to get the final
result we send it through the
measurement gate we see what the result
is so how the probability works is if
you have a value a B it collapses to 0
with probability a squared and 1 with
probability B squared so if we encounter
our familiar qubit from the previous
slide 1 over 2 1 over 2
it has a 1/2 chance of collapsing to 0
and a 1/2 chance of collapsing to 1 it's
like a coin flip now if we just measure
our classical qubit or a class we'll see
bits the the 1 0 has a 1% chance of
collapsing to 0 and 0 1 has a hundred
percent chance to collapse into one so
it's sort of an important in that way
and I I found it useful here to give
people a sort of physical intuition
about what we're doing what to see if it
is or qubit is if you've heard of
polarization you've probably bought like
fancy sunglasses it says that they're
polarized so polarization is actually
sort of quantum phenomenon you can be
polarized like this way or this way and
your glasses will be polarized a certain
way so we'll only let light polarized in
this way through basically it turns out
that qubits you can think of like this
yeah photon beam polarized this way is a
zero and photon being polarized this way
is a one superposition means it's
actually like both right so it could
actually go through both gratings and
then if you measure it and a way to
measure it is just to like fire it
through grating and like see whether it
goes through then you can collapse it to
0 or 1 so that's our sort of intuition
pinning this to a physical concept of
course modern we found that photons
actually make very very poor qubits they
tend to collapse too easily so we don't
use those but you can
you think of that does anyone have any
confusion here really about how this
this measurement process collapse
probable probability works okay great
we will learn about multiple qubits the
same is multiple C bits we represent
them by the tensor product it actually
was doing that okay hold on laser
pointer okay there we go no that's not
okay so if we have two qubits and we
multiply them the sum of squares
identity actually it it is maintained
and so if we consider our perfectly
balanced 50% coin flip cubit and we
tensor it with another coin flip cubit
we get this four vector with one half in
every single column and one half squared
is of course 1/4 so 1/4 plus 1/4 plus
1/4 plus 1/4 is 1 this maintains the
property and the way to read this is
when you measure these two qubits it has
a 1/4 chance of collapse into 0 0 0 1 1
0 1 1 this is sort of the probability of
when you measure it finding a 1 there
and 0 everywhere else so we could find
that there's a 1/4 probability of
finding a 1 in this position and all
zeros everywhere else does that kind of
make sense for multiple qubits ok great
you guys are just trucking along and no
problem it's to be super easy yes
absolutely
so only there's only going to be one one
one left in the vector yes there
couldn't there gonna be two ones there
could not be two ones because that would
actually violate our a squared plus B
squared equals one constraint but yeah
after measurement there will only be one
one here in this in this four vector
which we can then factor into two bits
actually okay yes you also have your
fine collapsing for that longer aventure
yeah yeah
so if you measure these two qubits at
once you can think of this product state
vector is collapsing and and then that's
just the probability of finding a 1 here
and a 0
everywhere else it'll become useful in
the future when we can't actually factor
out the product state but that's anyway
okay how about operations on qubits we
have these qubits how do we actually
manipulate them the same way we do with
the classical bits and all the matrix
operators we've learned also work with
qubits so for example negation if we
have our qubit that has a 25% chance to
collapse into zero 75 percent chance
collapse into one if we run it through
the bit flip operator now it has a 75%
chance of claps into zero and a 25%
chance to collapse into one so we can
manipulate these probabilities actually
called amplitudes with gates and you can
think of like a gates makes it they
correspond to some device scientists
have created which is sort of like mini
play the qubits with a gentle touch not
enough to like collapse them but enough
to like change their state so pretty
neat and there are also a couple
important matrix operators which we
haven't learned yet because they only
really make sense in the quantum context
the what is okay sorry okay all right
we're good the most important one is the
Hadamard gate and what it does is it
takes a zero or one qubit and it takes
it to the corn flip state where it's
exiting exactly equal superposition the
matrix looks like this it has one over
root two in every single entry except
for a negative in the bottom right
corner so if you multiply that by this
you get 1 over 2 1 over 2 if you
multiply this by 1 we get 1 over 2
negative 1 over 2 pretty neat so this is
how we actually get into superposition
we use the Hadamard device which
scientists have developed and we can
make much use of so kind of quits time
can anyone tell me why we need a
negative one in the bottom right corner
why do we need a negative sign here
it's like a matrix almost like provision
it's like a well the answer biscuit is
it has to be reversible so if we didn't
have this negative number here then both
0 and 1 would map to the same value and
it would not be reversible so we need
this negative sign yes correct
okay yes review of super position what
does that mean exactly in the super
position
yeah so super position means that at
qubit is it kind of in both state zero
and one at the same time and I want to
be some I guess really clear about
something here this doesn't mean the
qubit is secretly zero or secretly one
and we don't know it means it's actually
in both at the same time this is like
just quantum weirdness this is just like
what happens at the very very small
level of our world which is that things
don't have definite values until we
measure them zero when in super position
is 1 over Rho 2 1 over root 2 and 1 in
super position while root 2 minus ones
they seem to have different values but
they're representing conceptually the
same thing right which is so this kind
of comes down to the distinction between
the quantum and classical world which is
that from the classical perspective
these two qubits are kind of the same
they both have 50% probability of
collapse into 0 or 1 but with if we stay
within the quantum realm this sign
information is preserved as long as we
don't measure it and it can affect our
computations so kind of like it's got a
50/50 chance but it has a sensory used
to be a one has the sense that it used
to be one not really it's just it ends
up in this state which is different
within the quantum realm than this state
these are these are two different states
yes exactly both when you measure it and
convert it into the classical world come
down with a 50 50 50 chance yes but they
are different and they have different
computational properties ok now I'm
going to show you something really cool
about the Hadamard gate which it
actually takes us out of superposition
into the classical bits this should be
unsurprising everything's its own
inverse right if we just apply the
Hadamard gate to our value here our coin
flip value we get zero and for this one
we get one so this suggests to us a sort
of quantum computation structure we can
start with our classical bit values we
put them in the superposition do a bunch
of quantum stuff to them and at the end
if we're clever we can transition them
to zero or one so that our whole
computation was deterministic pretty
neat right okay now I should say that
not all algorithms work this way there
are algorithms like Shor's algorithm
which only gives the right answer 50% of
the time you can't be clever and always
get the right answer it's just not
doable but the one the problem we'll
look at does give this sort of
deterministic property so does anyone
anyone have trouble with this concept we
can transition out of superposition
without measurement pretty interesting
computation to quantum and then
converting it back yes that's better
like if I take 2 plus 2 how would that
look like in just the simplest of math
math what we're gonna go over that
basically we're gonna go over a problem
there are certain problems where corn
computers are better for than classical
like the addition is not one of them it
works the exact same way in both it
should also be said that all classical
computation can be done on a quantum
computer all you do is just restrict all
the values to 0 and 1 and it works but
it's kind of a waste because you can
also use all the extra values that we've
we found ok
and we've actually sort of defined a
state machine here which I'm sure many
of you will appreciate if your software
engineers or computer scientists here is
the action ok so this is this is the
unit circle which many of you will
remember from high school trigonometry
right it's a circle of radius one around
the origin here's the x axis this is the
y
axis you can think of the top value is
the coordinate on the value of the x
value and the bottom one is the Y value
so our zero value is at position one
zero which is along the x axis our one
value is at position zero one which is
along the y axis and this is the bit
flip operator it defines transitions
around this unit circle so 0 goes to 1 1
goes to 0 0 negative 1 goes to negative
1 0 which when you collapse them this is
0 this is 1 and vice versa excuse me and
if we look at the superposition values
here's something interesting the bit
flip operator really kinda has no effect
on them you know for this one if you
flip it upside down it's just it stays
itself same with this over here this
one's kind of interesting and then it
transitions you all the way across the
unit circle and we'll make use of that
but yeah ok this is pretty much the full
action of the bit flip operator on the
unit circle I should mention here that
if we were using complex numbers this
would actually be a sphere much more
difficult to sort of intuitively
represent or graphically represent so
we're sticking with real numbers they
sued us just fine but nice to know that
additional dimension is always available
to us if we want to make our computation
even more powerful and then here's the
action of the Hadamard gate which we saw
the past couple slides it takes us from
0 to 1 over 2 1 over root 2 1 to 1 over
2 negative 1 over 2 and kind of
symmetrically it also works in this way
over here so we have a nice state
machine that we've developed and now we
can start running things on the state
machine very nice and to ative sort of
representation you don't need to do
matrix multiplication all the time
everyone kind of gets this ok great
so here's an example of something we
could run through the state machine here
I'm introducing something called quantum
circuit notation you can the couldn't
think of the qubit traveling along this
line has these operations applied to it
as it goes through the boxes so X is bit
flip H is Hadamard and then so we go bit
flip how to learn Piplup how tomorrow a
bit flip and we if we start out here we
go a bit flip Hadamard bit flip how to
marred bit flip so we start out at 1 0
and get to 0 1 we got across
the circle and note this is reversible
so we can also go this way and get back
so this is kind of how we'll be we'll be
doing our all of our computations like
this basically just hopping around the
unit circle it's pretty simple pretty
intuitive right that's just a state
machine we've seen we use this in
classical computing all the time it just
has a bit of weird rules with uh flaps
and whatever but don't worry okay now we
have everything we need to learn the
simplest problem we're a quantum
computer of a form is a classical
computer we learned that C bits are just
a special case of qubits and qubits are
two vectors of complex numbers such that
a squared plus B squared it goes one
within that cubes can be in
superposition they are probabilistically
collapsed to see bits by measurement
Multi qubit systems we learned our
tensor products of single qubit systems
same is with cbits
matrices again represent operations on
qubits and we learned about the Hadamard
gate very important which takes our 0
and 1 bits to superposition and back and
finally we learned that we can think of
qubits in their operations is forming a
state machine on the unit circle or unit
sphere if we're using complex numbers
it's actually called the Bloch sphere BL
och sphere if you want to look that up
for the full complex numbers but unit
circle just fine for us ok so we're
gonna learn about something called the
Deutsch Oracle this is originally
proposed by David Deutsch and was it
like 83 or something like that and the
problem is this imaginary show up at
your doorstep and I give you a package
the package is just this black box it's
just a horrible present it's a black box
which has a function on one bit so I'm
one of those four functions on one bit
do you remember what those are I said I
would ask you about them set 0 set one
identity negation exactly so one of
those four functions I don't tell you
which one is inside this black box and
as a wire going in and a wire going out
so you can send in values see what goes
out but you can't actually look inside
the black box okay so how many queries
on a classical computer would it take to
figure out which function is inside the
black box - exactly you send in 0 see
what comes out you send in 1 see what
comes out
that'll uniquely identify which function
it is now how many queries do you think
it takes on a quantum computer you're
wrong it's to and I say this to
illustrate an important point which is
quantum computers they don't really
compute with all values simultaneously
at the end of the day you collapse your
qubit to a single bit of information and
a single bit of information is not
enough to uniquely identify four
functions one of four functions right
you need two bits at least so this
actually takes two queries on a quantum
computer well I'm not too exciting so
far now what if instead of not wanting
to know which function it is we just
want to know whether the function is
constant or variable so the constant
functions are the constant 0 constant 1
the origin mapped to 0 always with 2 1
the variable functions are identity and
negation so how many queries would this
take on a classical computer - you put
in 0 if you get 0 you don't know whether
it's identity or constant 0 if you get 1
you don't know whether it's bit flip or
constant 1 symmetrically with 1 so it
always takes 2 queries on a classical
computer even though there are 2
categories so really we only need a
single bit of information to tell us
which category it's in but how many how
many queries do you think it takes on a
quantum computer I've kind of burned you
last time so maybe you're a bit shy one
you are correct
we can do this in a single query on a
quantum computer we can tell whether
it's constants are variable this like
undeniably outperforms a classical
computer and we're gonna learn how ok we
do with the magic of superposition but
first we after that like define which
each either each of those four functions
look like on a corner computer we have
an instant obvious problem with the
constant functions can anyone tell me
what it is they're not reversible how
are we gonna write these non reversible
functions on a reversible computer this
is actually a really common problem in
quantum computation you really often
have to deal with non reversible
functions you have to write them in a
reversible way and the hack we do is
this so originally we had this right we
had an input and an output a single wire
going through and we just imagine that
you put in the value and you get
function applied to that value right but
the hack that you you always do on
quantum computers is you add an
additional output qubit so you actually
have two qubits we have to rewire our
black box so you have your input qubit
which is unchanged and then the value of
the function on this input qubit is
written to the output qubit does
everyone kind of get this is this is I
think the problem that people have the
most trouble with the this necessity the
the reason we have to do this is so we
can write non reversible functions in a
reversible way and the way to do that is
to have an a separate input and output
qubit
so when you see larger quantum
computations instead of having all the
bits go in and have transformations
applied to them and then being measured
you usually have a separate set of
output bits so the input bits go in they
have their value sort of written to the
output bits and you measure if the
output bits this is a very standard way
of doing quantum computation so does
anyone have any trouble with this this
is a very difficult concept so yes okay
okay so do you understand this model
basically this is what we have now okay
we need to rewire it so there are two
wires going through the box now okay and
one of those wires we call the input
wire one of those wires we call the
output wire we assume the output wire is
just initialize to zero right it's
always zero now our input wire is what
we actually give our input in like it'd
be like 0 or 1 or whatever value we want
to give this input to the function so it
goes through the box
it's just unchanged you know we don't
touch the value of the input wire but we
win a function if we calculate the
function in here on this input and then
we write its value to the output wire
okay yes we are we we are rewiring the
black box we have to rewire the black
box in order for the black box to really
work so the black box I gave you has to
be rewired
yes use the first which is the opposite
zero did I use the first input yeah
because one of them was kind of identity
right you put bigs out and then
the ethics one of them was exiled and
the other was so what'd it be so it out
right right so say so would say we only
had this right this is the old way of
doing it yeah we can't have a
non-reversible function in here right
for it to be on a quantum computer okay
okay right yeah so not saying is that on
the right side you have to going into
going up yes to going into going out yes
I get white to going out yes but they
don't get why the zero is also going in
it doesn't seem that you're actually
using it to produce any of the articles
yeah yeah you're correct it's just we
need no not really symmetry it's just
like how we write the quantum how we
would write the quantum circuit we would
need two qubits in general so and we
just you're correct that this output
value isn't really used no we do want it
to be zero because this the way that we
write the circuit assumes that this
value coming in is always zero yes well
that's it corner why is that in going of
goodbye our corner oh what's yeah yeah
so this is kind of weird that like the
output of the input is is called a but
but um we we basically only really look
at this value here is the basic idea
this is like the real output the input
will always be unchanged yes I have
multis two black boxes and series yes
the upper input which you have labeled
out valve that's right yeah it's a bit
weird and the second stage would be the
f of X output of the first stage yes
what okay so you're so you're saying if
you had two these in series rather than
sort of in parallel or what we're doing
is that what you're saying yeah I want
to do two operations one and then
another one and the black box is doing
some operation the black box is doing
some operation you can have as many
operations as you want in here inside
this black box basically true but I'm
trying to conceptually understand
whether I would take the f of X output
upper right
that would be the impetus for the
endpoint yeah the next one absolutely
and in fact I said that this black box
assumes this value is zero this is maybe
throw in a bit much of you but actually
we can break that assumption and send it
some other value which maybe will get us
some more information which is in fact
what we'll be doing so we the black box
the working of black box assumes that
the output input is zero but we can
break that assumption and be tricky my
way of thinking was I didn't have any
other value for the first stage but for
subsequent yes inputs I do have one so I
could use it if I want yeah you could
yeah and you might get some interesting
values which actually will okay does any
this I swear this is the most difficult
part conceptually of this entire
presentation so if anyone has any
trouble with it please just let me know
ask any questions we can spend as much
as long time on this as we want yes go
ahead
is there some okay well we'll go over
how we'll write each of the four
functions in this way so maybe that will
help so for example constant zero here's
how I would look X goes in X goes out
it's unchanged
now the output is always going to be
zero right that's just what the constant
zero does so we always want this value
in the upper right to be zero if we
assume zero goes in this is our circuit
diagram not neither of the two wires
make any modifications right they're
just it's a straight wire does that sort
of make sense
okay well see the next slide what about
for constant one we want suit we want
one to go out here right this is our
function output value and we've assumed
zeros the input here all we do is we do
a bit flip right here and that gets us
this the semantics we want there's
anyone having any trouble with this so
far I swear this is the most difficult
part so if you get this you you're
golden yes something like computation
and spare sure yeah you could
you can call like the the compute in
this parrot bit yeah that also works
they might reduce some can be
about there being an open open and input
okay why why is it called output because
it we call this the upper qubit because
it's just the place that we write to the
output of the function but we could call
like compute and spare or something like
that like like you suggested like this
would be the community this would be the
spare sort of bit that we write the
function output to yes why is this my
person can compare the reversibility of
these to my twice the right Barbara's
whole life
absolutely okay so let's consider this
one right here right we have our black
box with a single wire and say we want
to do the bit flip operator so that
would just be sorry not the Bethabara
the bit flip armory is reversible so we
want to do the constant 0 operator we
always want to map this to 0 so you need
some operation right here that would map
this to 0 but mmm it'll it'll be the
matrix 1 1 0 0 but this is not a valid
operator in a quantum computer because
it's not reversible so does that kind of
make sense it's just we can't construct
a device which does this it's just not
permitted by physical reality all this
math and stuff I'm showing you it's not
like special it's just we found that it
corresponds to the semantics and
workings of a quantum system and so it's
a nice way to reason about it basically
ok versus yeah of course if you want to
write constants 0 here with the 2 input
or the 2 wire model it would it would
just be blank right or if you want to do
this is constant one always maps to one
we saw that this has an X get here and
this is reversible right okay so we
managed to write a non reversible
function in a reversible way if you got
this congratulations this is the the
trickiest part it took me a while to
figure out why
to do this staring at the textbook does
anyone have any confusion here okay so
remember constant zero is just blank
constant one has a single ex gate yes
you always end up with a forward or
reversible matrix by doing this inside a
black box
yes yes black box is always a format for
reversal matrix applied to a product
State you're correct
although we will be not going into the
math in that way we'll just be using the
state machine to look at it but the math
is very easy for you to do it yourself
okay so let's let's look at identity
this is a bit more complicated this is
the C not gate okay where this is the
control and this is the target so we'll
end up with so input again is unchanged
we want output we assume it's zero we
want to end up with the value X right so
if zero is sent in here then this is the
target of control bit so the target bit
has just left unchanged right so zero
comes out if one is here one is sent in
then the control bits one so we flip
this bit and we end up with one does
this make sense this is kind of trick is
a bit a step up in complexity of our
circuit but everyone's fine with this
Wow okay
can anyone guess how will do negation
you could heart set the control bit to
one how can we hard set the control bit
to one not too controlled nots it is we
just have an X gate there so up to here
it's equivalent to identity right and
then we just flip the output bit and
then we get not X so those are the four
circuit values okay everyone's good so
far everyone knows how we write our four
functions are you ready to see how we
solve it on a quantum computer we use
this so we're gonna break the assumption
that this value goes into the black box
a zero we put first we initialize both
input and output qubits to zero we bit
flip them so now they're both 1 we put
them through the Hadamard gate to put
them into equal superposition then we
send them into the black box one of
those four circuits is applied then we
do the post-processing we send them
through the Hadamard gate again and we
measure them this is measurement and I
claim and I will show to you that if the
black box function is constant the
system will be in state 1 1 after
measurement like this will have value 1
this love value 1 we're using an input
is the most significant bit by the way
and if a black box function black box
function is variable from the state
system will be in state 0 1 after
measurement so this will be 0 this will
be 1 and we will know whether the
function is constant or variable in a
single query pretty nifty right I'm
going to show you how it's done
first the pre-processing remember we
start with 0 then we've been flip both
and how to Margate both so we start here
bit flip takes us up to here how to
Margate down here so this is the value
that is sent into the black box
just remember it's in the bottom right
on the unit circle this is the value
right before we send it through one of
those four circuits ok now let's look at
how we do constant 0 so constant 0
remember it's just blank on both and the
post processing is a single Hadamard
gate so since there no no gates are
applied they stay in this bottom right
the
and since the Hadamard gate is applied
as part of the post-processing we flip
back up here when we measure this this
is one one remember I said the value
would be one one if it were a constant
function so we're one for one okay so
you seem ok so far alright let's add a
bit flip because we're gonna go over
constant one now so this is the other
constant function now remember if we go
over if we do a bit flip in this state
we flip across the unit circle over here
and the Hadamard gate then takes us down
to here zero negative one when we
measure it we again get one one okay so
we're two for two not bad right okay
things get a bit more complicated does
anyone have any trouble with this so far
and in these yes Jim what why it
works out to one one
well that's a good question okay so
we're up here right if we measure this
then what value do we get this is just
one remember this this is the the value
of the one bit so if you measure one we
get one yes now down here if we measure
this we also get one because negative
one squared is one
so is one hundred percent chance hundred
cent probability of collapsing to one
and so we can say this is one one this
is like the most significant bit and
this is the least significant bit so we
end up with one one does that answer
your question okay great all right let's
go ahead on to something more
complicated which is C naught this is
going to get a bit weird well this is
how we do identity remember the input
bit is the control bit the output bit is
the target bit and don't panic I'm gonna
show you why this is on the next slide
but the action of C naught is to take
our input cubit up to here
it's the green line this is weird for
two reasons one is that the C naught is
supposed to leave the control bit
unchanged right but here this is the
only thing the control bit like the curl
it's the only thing that's changed and
this this sort of actions a bit odd but
don't worry I'm gonna show you the math
the reason why this works on the next
slide but just for now so we flip from
here up to here and then when we do the
Hadamard gate to post process we end up
in state 0 so 0 1 pretty neat ok here's
how the math works we ant we are
applying the C not gate to the state 1
over root 2 negative 1 over root 2 and 1
over 2 negative 1 over root 2 right when
we tensor these together we get this
ridiculous matrix which I'm going to
factor out 1/2 just to make it readable
so we have the matrix want our respector
is it 1 negative 1 negative 1 1 right
now we remember this familiar matrix
from the C naught slide when we apply
this matrix to this vector we get this
right we flipped the bottom two rows now
when we factor this remember this is the
product state and we can factor it into
the individual state where you get this
tensor product if you ignore everything
in the middle and just compare our start
values to our end values the this is the
output or least significant bit
this is unchanged right this is still 1
over 2 negative 1 over 2 the input bit
which we started out as 1 over 2
negative 1 over 2 ends up is 1 over 2 1
over root 2 this is just the action of
the gate so this is kind of a limitation
of our visualizer that we can't really
show the state transition but I hope
I've convinced you that this arrow is in
fact what happens does anyone have any
questions about this okay so we're three
for three right I said the value the
output value would be our the the
measure value would be 0 1 if it were a
variable function and indeed it is as I
said so 4 3 3 3 4 3 let's go over the
very last one which is negation it says
C naught and then a bit flip right let's
see how that works again we have this
arrow taking this up to here and the bit
flip takes us across the unit circle let
me do the Hadamard post-processing to
get a stone to here when we measure
these we get 0 1 4 4 4
huh single query I'll perform classical
computation pretty nuts right pretty
nuts okay so we did it we now we have
outperformed classical computing cost
computing is in the dust it's done it's
dead so we might think like yeah I see
how the math works and what's the
intuition I'm gonna tell you the
intuition the intuition is the
difference between the cab within the
categories was a single negation gate
right so if we go back to here so we
have constant 0 and constant 1 the only
difference between them is a single
negation gate when you apply a negation
gate in a super post state it's kind of
it doesn't really have any effect right
so we kind of neutralized the effect of
the negation gate so we neutralized the
difference within the categories and
then we magnify the difference between
the categories which is that the
variable functions have a C naught and
the constant functions do not so we
magnify the effect of the C naught and
minimize the effect of the negation and
that's the neat thing about that's a
powerful thing about quantum computing
which is that you can change the action
of various logic gates by putting
yourself in superposition in different
sort of states and stuff so that's
pretty neat and this problem you may say
like ok well yeah great whatever it's
really contrived when do I ever do this
in real life
that's a good question and it was
contrived back when it was announced I
think was 1993 but then a generalized
version of this funk of this function
was found which is it takes n bits as
input not a single bit and the n bits
either all mapped to the same value
let's re like that's 2 to the N possible
values they all map to the same value or
they equally map to 0 or 1 their
constant or balanced it's called so it's
a kind of just generalized version of
this it turns out we can still solve
that on a single query exponential
speed-up huh exponential speed-up the
single query versus on a classical
computer you have to try to all 2 to the
N values right before you know whether
it's constant or variable pretty nuts
okay
and there's there's a variant of that
problem building it everyone's kind of
like building on top of each other
it's called Simon's periodicity problem
it's again you have like a black box and
try and figure out some properties of
the function and that's actually and
then once that came around sure he
looked at this and he's like oh we can
use this to factor large integers and so
he came up with Shor's algorithm and
that's when like the whole field really
caught fire so about hope I've convinced
you that well this individual problem is
kind of contrived and not that useful
the it's the base like the foundation of
some very interesting computational
properties does that make sense anyone
have any questions you're all like
convinced that we just we just crushed a
classical computer right here yes on the
Microsoft site there's an article where
the girls saying that with with quantum
computers you can take programs and take
billions of years to run it this could
be that I mean yeah you have an
exponential speed-up
if you have like I don't know what would
take something like a billion years to
run like like if you have 80 and 80 bit
function like ^ 80 versus like a single
query that's probably a billion years
something like that so right but in what
context is that question an important
great question why do we care about this
sort of thing so for example in Shor's
algorithm you can construct a question
like does this integer have a certain
factoring structure basically and you
can tell a property like whether it has
that property or not basically which
will allow you to and if it does have
that property you can like factor it
pretty much it's very very hand Waverley
explaining how Shor's algorithm works so
you can construct a lot of problems in
terms of does this function have a
certain property or not which you can
find efficiently on a quantum computer I
hope yes
ah mainly mainly decision problems
although like as we know from
theoretical computer science decision
problems can be usually be turned into
like general to find me the answer
problems and vice-versa so yeah okay
pretty good so far and yep
to recap the whole presentation learned
how to model classical computation with
basically in your algebra we learned
about qubit superposition in the
Hadamard gate and finally we learned
about the Deutsch Oracle problem where
quantum out performs classical pretty
nifty huh
okay now the bonus topics with all the
tools we have these will be a breeze for
you you'll never have to read some pop
science article quantum entanglement and
like try and muddle through their
horrible metaphors you'll actually know
the math alright you'll know the math
that is incredible and we'll go over
quantum teleportation which is super
super nifty like it is mind-blowing okay
quantum entanglement you asked a great
question a very prescient question
earlier which is can we always factor
the product state into the qubit state
when we cannot do that that means that
the qubits are entangled
for example this state if we have qubits
in this state which is 1 over 2 0 0 1
over 2 if we try and factor this we can
so let's try and factor this we have we
should if we can factor it we should be
able to write it is the tensor product
of two matrices right where a times C is
1 over root 2 a times D is 0 B times C
is 0 and B times D is 1 over root 2 so
we have this set of equations right now
8 times 2 equals 0 that means a or D has
to equal 0 if a equals 0 then AC would
equal 0 and it doesn't so a cannot equal
0 if d equals 0 then BD would equal 0
but it doesn't so D cannot equal 0 so
the only solution is there is no
solution
we cannot factor this this is an
unfactored will State and what this
means is we cannot we cannot separate
these qubits they have no individual
value their value only makes sense
together they're called entangled and
the way we might think of this is that
this if we measure this state it has a
50% chance of collapsing two zeros
and a 50% chance of collapse into one
one so the qubits are coordinating right
does anyone have any confusion with this
sort of mathematical representation okay
let's talk about what it means well it's
not talked about what it means yet you
might be like well Andrew I can sling
any old value into the vector how do you
actually entangle qubits it's really
simple if we have two qubits we just put
one qubit through the Hadamard gate to
put it in superposition and then that
qubit is the control bit in a sea not
two gates that's all we need here's how
it works mathematically we start off
with zero zero we put the the most
significant bit in superposition right
and then here's our familiar matrix C
naught matrix if we apply it to the
product state we get this this is the
state from the previous slide right so
really simple to entangle qubits okay
what does this mean I mean they seem to
be coordinating or like communicating or
something in some way right these two
qubits and if you measure one qubit it
collapses the other in in coordinated
state now the weird thing here's how
we're getting into we're getting a
really weird stuff here okay
this happens across huge distances China
just this year managed to do this
between earth and a satellite in space
they entangled qubits put one half on
the satellite it was launched into space
when they measure them they're the same
value
it happens across huge distances it
happens faster than light it is
instantaneous a 2013 experiment
entangled qubits move them very far
apart synchronizing with an atomic clock
they measured them very close together
so close together in time that it would
have taken light 10,000 times longer to
pass to travel between them so they
aren't communicating with any sort of
radiation anything like that okay they
are it's instantaneous it's faster than
light and you might be like well it's
pretty obvious what's going on here when
the qubits were entangled they just
decided ahead of time what they're gonna
do right
well like that explains everything but
that's called hidden variable theory
this is hidden variable theory it's the
same reason that when a qubits in
superposition it isn't secretly zero or
secretly one it's both it's the same
thing and hidden variable Theory we're
not going to go over the proof why it
doesn't
but basically there's this guy named
John Bell and he showed that if hidden
variable theory were true it had some
really weird implications and therefore
it's untenable it's just the state it's
just how the universe works the they
coordinate faster than light they just
do that's nuts and you might be like
well I've been taught my entire life
there's a universal speed limit the
speed of light right like what's up with
that we can't just chuck it all out and
this was in fact a big source of
consternation to Einstein the idea that
locality wasn't true and then it was
discovered that there's a really
important qualifier it's you can have
faster than like coordination but you
cannot have faster than like
communication so information cannot be
communicated so think about it if I
entangle two qubits I give you one we go
to opposite ends of the universe if I
collapse mine all I know is that you
collapse yours when you collapse yours
you will see the same thing there's no
information that can be communicated
there really so faster than light
coordination is okay faster than light
communication not okay okay yes it does
in a way but communication here is a
technical term which means like you can
I have a bit of information that I can
transfer to you pretty much so I use the
term coordination to try and a give a
name to something which is not that but
still involves like some kind of
coordination I guess like I said this is
a limitation of our language all we can
do is is look at the math and see what
it does and our language is not it was
not developed for this anything I try
and tell you is fundamentally a lie
except for the math yes yes
I measure one and I know its value
mm-hmm does that mean that the other one
is still could potentially still not be
measured but when it is measured it will
have the same value right when you
measure one it instantly collapses the
other actually yeah good I mean I said
that's a simplification again of
language but you can think of it that
way yes sorry
so there there's no way to tell that
something has been class they're not
that excellent question if you could
tell whether something's been collapsed
or not that you could measure when he
used that his synchronization
faster-than-light synchronization right
yeah you can't you the process of
telling whether something's class in
superposition or not would just collapse
it if you would be able to tell through
some of those sort of quantum
computation make you do some computation
on it and it was collapsed it would only
be this state and if it wasn't it would
sometimes be this sometimes you that you
would think so but in fact it is not the
case shut up and calculate that's a good
like way out I'm not sure I can't say it
intuitively I can I can say that if you
do put up just pencil and paper it try
it try it yourself try and come up with
some sequence of operations you could do
on the other qubit which would reveal it
as having being collapsed or not then
maybe but yes doesn't this coordination
communication yes this is the critical
thing it does not violate causality if
we could communicate then it would
violate causality but since we
coordinated it does not violate whether
you said was if you measure the other
one is going to be yes yes yes
yeah act of measurement is in your
control right yes so how can that happen
on the other side or the other qubit
yeah
you don't have communication well we'll
let let's define what communication is
communication is I have a bit either
zero one and I'm able to send it to you
in some way somehow yeah yes state that
is not last be communicated yeah I mean
like this is a language problem
they're the qubits are like
communicating but we can't get
information through them basically you
could like be able to say that or I use
the term coordinating to try and avoid
this problem others other times in the
literature you'll just see the word
correlated which tries to like avoid
that whole problem
the word here is when you were using it
it has an action that you have performed
yes so you yes you control when you
measure you cubit it collapses the other
but there's no way you can change
causality in that other cubits frame
basically there's no way you can get
information from your frame into that
frame which would affect their causality
all we can know is we can we have
generated the same random numbers
basically yeah I want to avoid that pre
coordination is the Cubist decided ahead
of time yeah which is not the case but
until yeah at the time they measure they
like decide which whether they going to
0 1 and they somehow communicate that
coordinate correlate whatever to the
other qubit and it goes in the same yes
[Music]
great question
we're gonna get into quantum
teleportation on the very next slide
first I want to tell a funny story about
this so you may have heard the phrase
spooky action at a distance this is
Einstein coined that he was referring to
this so Iestyn Podolsky and Rosen or
three physicists who actually came up
with the idea of quantum entanglement
they call it the EPR paradox they're
like the workings of quantum mechanics
result in this this is obviously absurd
therefore quantum mechanics is garbage
was the basic argument but then the
experiments came out and they're like no
this is how it works this is the
universe is in fact absurd locality is
broken and so it's kind of funny that
like a pair of the pair of paradoxes are
originally designed to like discredit
quantum mechanics turned out to be the
actual way the universe works I think
it's a great little story ok any other
questions about entanglement yes let's
see the same yes if we say that this has
a process or probability collapsing to 0
collapsing to 1 and then we observe that
it collapses to 1
yes how can we justify that our
presumption that it had a probability of
c20 mmm was very excellent question
excellent question the answer is you
just do it all bunch of times and you
see that you get a 50% distribution of
values exactly they hang at the same
time experimentally we know that they
occur at the same time with the 2013
experiment adding tango qubits took them
far apart they used okay see the scene
Cuban yes it happened in climax yes and
now you take another pair of qubits and
this is another pair of qubits but not
necessarily the same ones yes so until
it happened at that time that space over
you can't really tell that this was
happening probability 1/2 you're
questioning ok so they could have
decided ahead of time for example maybe
it works probability works I mean it's
just the the the amplitude squared gives
you the classical probability of it
collapsing to 0 or 1 I guess I'm not a
hundred percent sure what you're driving
at so once observed then we rationalize
yes and then if we do that a whole if we
do the experiment a whole bunch of times
we see that it's about a 50% chance of
them both being 0 or both being 1 which
in fact I will show that to you live on
the quantum computer that we do that ok
all right let's move on teleportation
this is the actual use which you asked
about and you've probably read about
quantum teleportation again in pop
science articles needless to say their
explanation was complete trash it made
no sense at all but now we'll make sense
to you ok
it's the process by which we take an
arbitrary qubit state and transfer it
across space and time somewhere else so
you use entangled qubits is a sort of
bridge to send a qubit from one place to
another and here's a very important
thing it's called the no-cloning theorem
you can transfer qubit States so you can
cut and paste them but you cannot copy
them you cannot copy and paste a qubit
say you cannot clone it this is called
the no-cloning theorem it's actually
pretty simple to prove you just show
that any offset operation would not be
reversible or its own inverse but we're
not gonna go do that and here's an
important thing the teleportation
despite using a faster-than-light
phenomenon of entanglement is not itself
the whole protocol is not itself faster
than light for communication because you
actually must exchange two classical
bits so if I'm teleporting my qubit to
you in addition to us having an
entangled cubed per I also have to send
you two bits of information and we'll
show why that is in the next slide so
everyone kind of conceptually grasp the
I guess the purpose of quantum
teleportation okay so here's what the
circuit looks like we're not going to go
over the math there are appendices to
this slide deck which I will you can see
after the class to go over the math but
it gets a bit complicated so we're not
going to do it so we have the qubit that
we want to be one to teleport here we
call it t and its value is V it's just
this generic qubit value can be any
value and then we have these two qubits
a and B which are both initialized to
zero now you'll recall this is the
entanglement circuit so these two qubits
are entangled all right now after
they're entangled we'll say we have
Alice and Bob Alice wants to send her
entangled qubit to Bob so Alice has
these two qubits Bob has this qubit and
these two qubits are entangled
so the first so the qubits are like
these two qubits are separated right
after being entangled basically now
Alice then entangles
her qubit she wants to teleport with the
other two qubits so it's a three qubit
entangled system if you were to write
out the product state you wouldn't be
able to factor it into three qubits then
she puts this qubit through the Hadamard
gate finally Alice measures both qubits
in her possession and those are the two
and this results in two classical bits
these are the two bits that Alice has to
send to Bob and the measurement result
of this bit determines whether Bob
to put an ex run its cubit his cubit
through an ex are a bit flip gate and
the measurement result of this cubit to
controls whether Bob has to run his
cubit through a new type of gate which
we haven't seen before it's called the
phase flip gate or Zed and this is what
the matrix looks like and basically once
Bob has applied those two gates or
neither gate if both of these end up
being 0 Bob doesn't have to apply
anything he'll end up somewhat magically
with Alice's cubit value she wants to
teleport pretty nifty huh pretty nifty
and you might be like well we're already
exchanging a cubit here why do we even
care like we're obviously just giving
the cubit to Bob like couldn't we just
Alice just give her cubit like right
right there so what you can do is you
can pre entangle like a whole bunch of
cuba it's like a few billion cubits or
something and then you ship them by mail
they're called EPR halves you like ship
them by mail or something so Alice and
Bob have like a big repository of these
entangled qubits and that anytime Alice
wants to send a qubit to Bob she can
just use up one of the EPR pairs EPR
halves
yeah EPR pairs and at that point that
EPR have a pair pair has been collapsed
can no longer be used so it's it's a
non-renewable resource but Alice can
just send as many qubits as she wants
over to Bob okay now you might be saying
well I don't really got this of the math
is in the appendix if you really want to
go see it it gets that's pretty pretty
complicated but I think I did an okay
job of explaining it so okay uh you
might see it might be like okay oh by
the way I forgot to say really cute
really really important thing you may
have heard that we can simulate quantum
computers on a classical computer but it
takes exponential slow down or
exponential memory this is the reason if
two qubits become entangled you have to
keep their full products data round so
if like n qubits become entangled you
have a vector of size two to the N you
have to keep in memory and that is why
it takes exponential memory to simulate
a quantum computer on a classical
computer pretty nifty okay
so you may be like okay this is all
pretty interesting further learn
Engels you can learn the Deutsch Josa
algorithm that's the one with n bits
that I talked about and also Simon's
periodicity problem which is another
figure out some property about this
function I'm not going to talk about the
complexity stuff but anyway you can also
learn insurers I love them Grover
Grover's algorithm quantum cryptographic
key exchange that one's actually pretty
simple I recommend looking at that you
can learn how they're actually
implemented in physical terms if you
care about that
an important thing quantum error
correction since these systems are so
small like a spare cosmic ray could just
come out of nowhere and just wreck your
entire computation you need very very
stringent error correction schemes so I
think theoretically it takes five
physical qubits for a single logical
qubit like we've been operating at in
practice it's looking more like we'll
need one or two hundred to get like a
qubit of like a hundred percent
probability like we've been using pretty
much so that's something to keep in mind
like when we see like Google's coming
out with a thirty cubic computer that
maybe doesn't mean as much as we'd hope
[Music]
maybe it'll only get us like two or
three really high quality qubits and
also quantum programming language design
which I will go over because I'll show
you a Q sharp example but anyway
recommended textbooks this one is my
absolute favorite has the same title is
the name of the talk quantum computing
for computer scientists this algorithm
is by our friend David Merman the shut
up and calculate guy he it is a meat
grinder of a textbook but I started out
with this when he was horrifying
it was just like but it skips a lot of
steps basically it's more symbolic
manipulation you won't see as many
vectors and matrices I like to write out
the met vectors and matrices to see
what's going on
which gets really unwieldy when you're
ready to know like a 64 by 64 vector or
matrix but I like to have both of these
you know so I like I'm I'll use this to
fill in the gaps with this this has more
interesting to side stuff like that this
is also in the MS Library there's
another one called quantum computing and
gentle interaction also in the MS
Library I've heard mixed reviews or so
many decent reviews of it I haven't
looked out of myself there's also the
Microsoft quantum development kit they
have the docs they're actually pretty
nice they included quantum peter
simulator and Q sharp as well see now I
said I would end the talk on some
skepticism
which there's an article came out I
think was quanta magazine pretty
prominent recently interview with a
mathematician who believes that
physically realizable quantum computers
cannot exist his basic argument
simplifying is that the amount of noise
in the system grows exponentially with
the number of qubits so we cannot get a
really large qubit system because if our
our computation will just keep
collapsing in the middle of it and like
well it's just like it's an exponential
term and so I would be very sad if this
happened I'd feel like the universe is
against me it'd be really it'd be very
sad if we could not realize the benefits
of quantum computing some like
cosmically sad but anyway wouldn't you
know can't argue with the universe and
yeah you can read that article for some
skepticism I think his name is Gill coli
is the mathematician there's some
appendices but I'm gonna do some demos
now okay the first demo is just the
Deutsch article problem in Q sharp so Q
sharp is based on F sharp and we have
this function I've written is black box
constant you take in a black box and I
tell you whether it's gone oh gosh sorry
here of course okay we have our function
is black box constant where it takes in
a black box and it just returns a bool
is it constant or not and it just uses
the same protocol we went over it
allocates two qubits calls one input one
output clears them sets them both to
zero does the pre-processing flips them
puts them through the Hadamard gate then
it sends them into the black box
afterward it again puts them through the
Hadamard gate and then it measures both
of them and again if if the input result
is one then it's constant otherwise it's
variable okay we have our black boxes
defined here so constant 0 again
remember it's nothing for constant one
we flip the output bit for identity we
run a C naught gate with input of
control up at his target and the
negation will you seen on next
and we just have these like is zero
constant zero I call is blackboard
constant with constant zero and then we
have our classical driver any quantum
computation will have a sort of
classical computer to tell it what to do
and so we just I ask for you to those
four well what's going on and we can run
it and it runs on a simulator and we see
the output is constant zero constant
true constant one constant true identity
constant false negation constant false
so there you go yeah we wrote the door
charcoal ran it on a real quantum
simulator you saw though it worked out
ok the final demo of the day and then
I'll let you get out of here is there we
go
this is called the IBM quantum
experience there is a real like world
quantum computer that IBM is built it
only has four five cubits but they just
let you online just drag gates onto this
quantum circuit diagram and run it on a
real quantum computer so I thought it'd
be pretty nifty if we demonstrated
entanglement right live for you on stage
let's see so if you remember the first
thing we do is you drink a Hadamard gate
onto one bit and then we use the control
knot I don't know okay so the way the
quantum computers are constructed you
can also you only usually put C knots
between certain debts basically it's
just kind of otherwise it's just
mechanically impossible to see can we do
that
nope okay how about so
okay we did it here's our this is the C
not gate you can see varying
representations of it it's like the o
plus and I I say we'll run it on a
quantum computer
alright measurement gates I forgot we
need to add the two measurement gates
obviously so we're measuring both these
qubits after entangling them and what we
expect is to see them predominantly
being 0 0 and 1 1 right well let's test
it we'll call it that and because we can
say the result from cache but I want to
do it live for you guys so I'm gonna run
a new execution and you can imagine
right now deep in an IBM research lab
nestled within a dilution refrigerator
operating it slightly above absolute
zero we have real qubits being entangled
and measured thousands of times for our
entertainment that's pretty cool that's
pretty cool ok
ah let's see if it's oh here we go we
got the results and executions is it
it's it's pending ok so it might take a
couple minutes we can say you know does
anyone have any questions while we're
waiting for this yes this experiment
where they sent an entangled cubed up to
space in the satellite yes
are we good at storing like qubits for a
long time but I'm really surprised they
were able to do that they were managed
to send the entangled to keep it up file
laser but yes ok I don't think we're
that good at storing qubits for a while
I think they're fairly short-lived but
yes they actually this Chinese satellite
experiment they teleported to cube it up
there so they sent one EPR half of by a
laser and then they use that EPR half to
teleport the qubit up there
pretty cool yeah you can send entangle
cubes by laser yes yeah
let's see it's still not okay that's
fine anyway yes there is this new
article by the mathematician that says
the noises I'm gonna grow faster yes the
whole purpose of the topological one
computer is to resist that of course any
corner computer will have issues with
noise the topological corner computer is
supposed to be better than its IBM
counterparts in terms of noise but it'll
still grow exponentially like it can
still be better but it still runs with
the exponential barrier and so this the
next couple years are really sort of
make or break for quantum computing
because we were happy we're we a now
have the ability to create computers
which run into this exponential term if
it exists if it exists and so we will
see within the next couple of years
whether quantum computing is really
possible or not it's it's nervous makes
me it makes me nervous but yeah because
we'll we'll run into this limit probably
like this year if if Google does not
manage to demonstrate quantum supremacy
it's it'll be a bit scary I guess but uh
yeah let's see we don't have any yes you
know what Google use this one I don't I
don't believe we do I think they just
have it is actually we know they haven't
they haven't announced what they use it
for um my manager is actually playing
around with the d-wave simulator 2d
wavers Canadian W yeah everyone's like
everyone's out there like really scammy
and not really quantum how everyone kind
of believes that their quantum but it's
a different paradigm
it's like optimization basically but it
uses quantum computing my matter they
have a simulator you can use my managers
been using it to kind of play around
with finding routes in a network it has
like general applications like that wow
this is taking a while yeah it's in the
invitation and I think it'll be probably
be posted on the
you the resident website or all posted
online yeah yeah it's like it's
optimized you you're able to express the
network graph in terms that like an
optimization result would be the like
the least energy path in terms of like
the the least cost path through the
graph sort of but that's different than
the way that in the I'll be really sad
if this isn't uh doesn't finish in time
oh well I'm doing I saw a presentation
it's only saying that you could do
classically faster than what they were
over don t wait so they've approved it
now or I don't know actually I haven't
looked into that um it's probably
they're probably about comparable I
would say it cuz if given that it's just
like optimization and especially with
the explosion of machine learning
there's been a lot of development in
making an optimization better
optimization is like you have a surface
and you're trying to find like the
highest point or the lowest point so
there's there's been a lot of research
that goes into that well that's how
about we here we'll just run it from
cache and okay here we go okay so here's
the results from cache unfortunately our
real execution didn't finish yet but so
we see that indeed they entangled some
different qubits the nervous but we end
up with 0 0 & 1 1 almost exclusively but
then there's some in the middle because
of the error rate right so this is on a
real quantum computer we have some error
rate where it doesn't exactly work
according to our model all the time but
pretty cool these are entangled and
they're measured and we have that that's
the experimental data right there that
entanglement is a real thing yeah ok
that's concludes the presentation thank
you very much I feel I hope you all feel
as though you followed the whole thing
no real confusion and feel that you
could keep on learning this isn't like
mad genius science this is very
accessible science so yeah thank you
very much
[Applause]